it's great to have back on the program
today dean baker who's a senior
economist at the center for economic and
policy research and also a visiting
professor at the university of utah
uh dean we we spoke about a year ago
most recently
and uh we now have a very uh different
situation
from the standpoint of the pandemic
economically
what are you most paying attention to
and what is of concern at this point
well the economy is recovering rapidly
and that that's a very good story i mean
we still have a lot of people out of
work we're still not back to
what we might consider normal certainly
far from full employment
but to my view the question is the rate
at which we're going
and the extent to which we see obstacles
one of the big things or the big thing
of course is the pandemic itself i mean
we have
uh the numbers way way down because
primarily because of the vaccines which
have been great but we know there's a
lot of people who don't want to take
them
and as a result of that they're getting
sick there so
that's a bad story now as it stands i
don't think there's a big economic
problem with that i mean i want to
trivialize people getting sick and dying
that's a big deal but i mean if we're
just talking about the economic impact
i think that's relatively limited the
big concern
and you know this should be a huge
warning to us we of course are talking
about the delta variant and
the vaccines are still effective from
that but as long as the pandemic is
spreading out of control
not here i mean obviously we care about
here too but
around the world we're not going to be
safe and that's a really really big deal
so i wish we had done i wish we still
now do more to get the world vaccinated
so that's a really really big story
but the other part just how things look
in the economy right now well we've had
fantastic job growth the last four
months over 600 000 a month
um we're going to we'll get a gdp report
next week and the second quarter's
almost certainly going to put us above
where we were pretty pandemic i mean we
have a ways to go yet to be back on
trend
but most things are looking pretty good
and so
you know as the economy goes i'm feeling
pretty good about it you know we just
have to make sure we could
slow the growth of the pandemic partly
here but
probably more importantly right now
around the world there's been this um
refrain or talking point call it what
you will
in the context of this enhanced
unemployment benefit
that the federal government established
during the pandemic
that now as things are opening there's a
worker shortage
businesses are having trouble finding
people to work
because people quote would rather sit at
home and collect their enhanced
unemployment
now we have some early data from some
states that decided to
get ahead of joe biden's september date
and just cut the enhanced unemployment
early
it's not totally clear that it's really
having
a definitive impact actually on
the the rate at which people are
starting to look for jobs or being hired
generally speaking my view is most
people want to work
and most people find for better or worse
they find meaning and identity through
work and that could be a bad thing or a
good thing we could talk about that
but that the kind of free rider the
people who just would prefer to sit at
home and not work
are so so small in number that they're
not significant
what's your sense of that talking point
yeah well
you know everyone's got their lazy cause
and who's sitting at home collecting
benefits and they
extrapolate the whole world and that's
how many lazy kids out there actually
exist but in any case you know everyone
could
say they know someone and some people
surely are but
there's been a lot of research on this
and remember we had 600
a week supplements back in the original
cares act right and there were a number
of efforts to study the impact of that
and they found
it was very little it wasn't zero i mean
obviously there's some people that will
make a difference
for but there was relatively little
impact and you mentioned that now you
have several states that have
uh jumped the gun or whatever term you
want to use they've suspended ended the
benefits early
and my friend aaron baze at the
university of massachusetts he
analyzed what the performance has been
in the states that have been to benefits
early compared to other
states and there's no difference in fact
i think there's a very very small uptick
i'm not going to blame it on that but i
think they actually
had somewhat higher unemployment or rise
in unemployment relative to other states
so the idea that that's a major factor
in keeping people from looking for work
i just don't buy it what i do think is
going on is you have a lot of businesses
reopening at the same time and the
biggest story of course is restaurants
that's the one that was
hardest hit right and now they're
reopening so they're looking all higher
a lot of workers at the same time
and it shouldn't be surprising that
that's that's not that easy that that
you know they're in a situation they
can't get the workers they need they're
bidding up wages
i mean that's a good thing in my view
but in any case um that's really not a
terribly surprising story nor
necessarily a bad story
and in any case it doesn't seem as
though the unemployment supplements are
big part of the picture
is it as simple as some others are
saying which is well it's just
now the businesses the the employers
need to
compete for the apparently temporarily
limited pool of potential workers
and this should just mean that they pay
more and then it'll solve everybody's
problem like is it that simple
it is i think that's basically a story
and some businesses say that well i
can't afford to pay higher wages
and i'm sure in some cases that's true
and you know look this is a capitalist
economy
and you know some businesses businesses
go out of business all the time i mean
it sure was that i mean i know people
put their
put a lot of work in many cases their
life savings you know
so so i don't mean to trivialize that
but that is the reality
so in some cases we'll have situations
where businesses
just aren't going to be profitable and i
understand they don't want to
say well if i get away with paying
workers 10 an hour rather than 15 you
know things
but sorry you know that's that's going
to be the world
and uh so so i just don't see this as
the big crisis that's being portrayed as
on uh the the other side of this is
pricing
and inflation um during the pandemic
we saw really significant increases in
some
products lumber but was a big one that
had some sort of follow-on effects in
terms of
uh building of new construction homes
renovations
etc the price of lumber has now actually
dropped precipitously
although that drop does not yet seem to
have filtered through
as much as it maybe will to the end
products that the lumber is
is used for some of the inflation data
that we see
compared for example may 21 to may 20.
so you're sort of comparing to
when there was a significant demand
collapse and maybe that's not the right
way to look at it
what's your perspective on this issue of
inflation
well i think for the most part it's
reasonably well under control so again
the may to may comparison
or now we're in june to june but i mean
that's you know it's kind of silly
because it's you know these are months
where prices were badly depressed so
if you look at what inflation's done
since february the last pre-pandemic
month
it's up some there's no doubt about it
but an overwhelmingly large share of
that is simply cars both new and used
cars and we know what the story is there
um there was a fire in a semiconductor
factory in in japan and that's led to a
worldwide shortage of semiconductors
which has limited the the production of
new cars
and what that's mean is people who have
money now from the the various uh
pandemic programs they want to buy a car
new cars they can't get new cars so they
buy a used car
and use car prices have just gone
through the roof they've actually begun
to fall by some measures as of june so
we'll see how that pans out over the
rest of the year
but that's the bulk of the uptick in
inflation so
it's hard to get too concerned about
that my expectation is that we're going
to see those prices
falling through the rest of the year i
mean they'll still be higher than a 220
level but they're going to be falling
from where they were
in june so i'm not that concerned about
that other areas of the new york times
had a big piece on housing
um house prices sale prices have risen a
lot
and that's because a lot of people are
moving that we have very low mortgage
interest rates
and you have a lot of people that are
moving from expensive places like new
york washington where i came from and
they're moving to cheaper places around
the country and push putting up big
upward pressure on prices there
um new york and some of the more
expensive ones it's price growth is
sloan in some cases actually going
negative but
you know but that's that's a big story
now whether that leads to
sustained increase in rents i think it's
a little too early to tell i was struck
you know this isn't necessarily a good
story but if we're trying to tell the
picture of the housing market
we have to consider we're ending the the
the
eviction moratorium that ends at the end
of this month
and their reports i think these are
exaggerated that somewhere around seven
or eight million people face eviction
i don't think anything like that will
actually be evicted but a lot of people
will be
you know and again i know i'm not saying
it's a good thing i'm just saying if
we're looking at the housing market and
let's say we have eight hundred thousand
people victim i'm pulling that somewhat
out of the air
but it will be a lot um that's a lot of
vacant units
um so you know it's again i don't mean
to say any of this is good that isn't
but we have a lot of turmoil in the
economy right now which has led to
inflation in some areas you know as
mentioned in cars i could identify some
others
um but it's not an underlying it's not
the sort of inflation we saw in the 70s
where you had
higher wages driving higher prices
leading workers to push for higher wages
and then we got the spiraling upward
we're very very far from that story you
mentioned
in the car um discussion that
now part of this is people have money to
spend and they want cars as they they
get back to things
one of the interesting things that we
saw so to kind of set this up
pre-pandemic frequently we would see
articles with headlines like
uh 40 of americans would need to borrow
to meet an unexpected
400 expense and about the the point of
those stories was
very low savings rate in the united
states
during the pandemic we saw headlines
about
dramatically higher savings rate in the
united states
at a macroeconomic level how should we
think about that because there's a
school of thought
that keeping money in bank accounts
instead of spending it has a very low
economic multiplier
and is not so good for the economy
although at the individual level
certainly we can understand how having
an emergency fund
is a very good thing for a household
budget so how should we be thinking
about that
well there's two issues here one is if
we're thinking of just immediate demand
in the economy
that does restrain demand so if i have
uh you know i got my
1200 or 1400 dollar check from president
biden
and uh go okay well i'm gonna put in the
bank because i don't need to spend it
right now
well if we're worried about inflation
that's actually a good thing
so so for word there's going to be too
much demand in the economy that's a good
thing
so i think as that has worked out it's
basically been a positive for the
economy in the sense that
as we're having this reopening and
there's a lot of
uh stress in different areas it probably
is a good thing that everyone doesn't
rush out and spending it now
say six months a year down the road as
you say the the flip side the micro side
is
okay i've got money in the bank i feel
better and we know i mean there's a lot
of data
people's balance sheets are better than
they've been in decades right now so
things
really look much better so that's great
both in their security but also
maybe they want to do a big ticket
purchase maybe they're going to use that
money as
a down payment on a house or a car
whatever it might be
so i consider that overwhelmingly a
positive that
again if we're worried oh we need more
demand in the economy right now
then people saving is definitely a bad
thing but we're not in that situation or
at
least
i don't believe we're in that situation
so i'm very happy to see that a lot of
people are in a situation where they
could save some of their money
and again they could always keep it
there as a reserve or they may decide
six months a year down the road to have
a big ticket purchase
two other um i don't know if we would
call them trends or things that have
kind of
been topics of conversation as a result
of the pandemic one is
is work from home and the different
decisions that are being
taken by made decisions being made by
corporations about
we will do permanent possible work from
home or we will do
a split of work from home and be back in
the office etc that's one
trend the other one is we're also
getting more and more
information from these four day a week
work trials which sometimes
are a full 40 hours but over four days
and sometimes they're actually fewer
hours like a 36 or 37 hour week over
four days and looking at
what employee productivity is over that
period of time rather than 40 or 45
hours
what's your thought on these things uh
at sort of this point in time but also
bigger picture
i think they're both very encouraging
trends taking one at a time yeah
the word from home clearly we're going
to see way way
more work from home than than we did pre
pandemic i mean the point is
um you know business and nurse is an
incredibly
powerful force in the economy people
have to appreciate that i
for a long time is an economist like oh
maybe it should be like this rather than
that
and go well maybe it should be but it's
not going to be well right
once employers got used to having people
working from home and they kept their
business operating
then they can't say it doesn't work they
know it works so we are going to see
many more situations where either people
are totally working from home
or cases where maybe they come in once
twice a week from the office and
i think that's a great thing from a
number of different perspectives uh
obviously it saves a normal enormous
amount of resources on commuting
right um people's time i mean obviously
people value their time and if you're
commuting two hours a day one hour each
way um that you're you're wasting a lot
of time i know anyone i mean there's a
lot of things we could argue how much do
you like this or that
i know anyone likes their commute and
you know i'm sure someone somewhere does
but
that's i think um i think just to
interject one idea there
there are some studies about if you have
a 15 minute commute
that it seems sort of for a lot of
people to be a positive kind of
change of phase from home to work and
that that
you know once you get longer than that
the duration of it seems to start having
like a more of a net negative effect
yeah i can believe that i mean a short
enough commute i
can grant isn't a big deal you know i
used to walk to work i was lucky enough
for
for a period of time to be able to walk
to work it was maybe half mile so
yeah you know rough you know 10 minutes
or so so yeah that was fine
that didn't bother me unfortunately i
think the vast majority of commuters
have considerably more
time so so i think that's a great thing
and i think it's it's good of course
from environmental perspective uh
you know where people don't have
obviously a lot of resources are wasted
in uh
commuting so so that's a great story um
four day work week i think similar story
again if you compare the us to europe
um there have been sharp reductions in
work hours over the last four decades in
i was going to say most all european
countries and
we now are average work year in the
united states 20 25
longer than it is in germany and
netherlands denmark you know other
wealthy countries
and i think most people do value their
time and if we could have a four day
work week rather than a five that's
great and yeah i'd love to see the hours
cut because i think a 10 hour day
certainly in a lot of jobs people would
find exhausting so
if we can make it a nine hour day uh
maybe somewhere down the road make an
eight hour day but whatever
uh nine hours isn't that much worse than
eight so you know i think
most people consider that pretty good
deal and again getting back to the
commuting if you have four commutes
rather than five that's
that's a plus so i'd love to see us get
to
shorter work years and a four-day work
week's really good way to go
uh without a doubt i'm i'm with you
there dean uh we've been speaking with
dean
baker who's a senior economist at the
center for economic and policy research
also a visiting professor at the
university of utah
always great having you on well thanks
for having me on good questions